you can't die you can't die really what
do you mean you can't die she thinks she
thinks that I'm gonna die soon why well
because when we had sucks doesn't it his
penis broke no no we had sex last week
tell him what you said to me it was just
a different kind of breathing pattern
this it was it was like chained Stokes
it was like you sure he wasn't orgasm II
know it's like a we I was doing the work
and he was wheezing I'm like how is this
on top of me right and she's doing her
thing right I hurt your arms you're not
a fish she was like you know dude what
do you call it like wait okay well girl
flailing Oh cowboy what is it
and everything she would bounce down I
go like my I couldn't breathe
did you have a lot of cheese or milk
that day yeah I feel like I'm dying do
you do you smoke cigarette I could feel
it how long you were here since I was 17
okay so long and then when we um I did I
come help me be they come I think I did
cook a couple days no I get this thing
where I went he had what are those mini
strokes he had like five words the show
and then can I just say something right
now please when I was in Utah this last
weekend I couldn't breathe on stage
I now know so I've been cutting down on
the cigarettes a little bit yeah I I
quit smoking because I had a I was on
tour and I completely lost my voice and
then this woman from Mob Wives named Big
Ang died oh yeah I remember her
yeah she's and I felt like I was
destined to be Big Ang and when she died
it was so sad she had like all the
cancers and yes and I left was it
genetics or because she smells okay she
smoked like chain-smoking I think she
smoked those like like not dejar on this
but something like that
but anyway just you lose your voice and
like I can't lose my voice you know yeah
how did you do it I use I I did a jewel
I I was like I checked like a
chain-smoker like for you know I mean I
guess it would go off and on but I
smoked heavily like but my voice was
always kind of [ __ ] up no I love your
voice your voice is what makes you you
thank you but I want to know was it I
mean cuz I try I go I go I want to quit
I'm gonna quit I I quit from a Jew from
the jewel it was the only thing that
work what's the tool it's like an
incredibly strong it's like the like the
Mercedes of like et cigs and
[Music]